[Music]  in many countries it is against the law  to hire a woman to be a surrogate mother  to carry a pregnancy for pay some US  states permit the practice that the  total cost is around $100,000 more than  many couples can afford seeking a more  economical alternative many couples from  Western countries seeking surrogates now  go to India where paid pregnancy is  legal in a source of employment for  rural women Indian women received around  6,000 to 8,000 dollars for carrying a  pregnancy about one third of what  surrogates in the US are paid but more  than the Indian surrogate mothers would  otherwise earn in a lifetime  suppose it were up to you as an Indian  legislator to decide whether to permit  or to prohibit commercial surrogacy how  would you vote  [Music]